when Anne Collins gets home there's
always a doctor in the house albeit a
virtual one that's thanks to a package
that could contain the future of
healthcare
the devices inside the dockler kit
measure her pulse breathing and blood
pressure
and send readings to medical
professionals via a smartphone you just
have to wait a little bit it means a
chronic pulmonary respiratory disease
doesn't require a hospital stay I was
happy
I thought what a good idea yeah I didn't
want to stay in hospital in hospital you
can't sort of be going out into the
gardens when you're at home I think you
recover better you're around friends and
family but you're being looked after
you're being monitored so you've got
that in the background and that helps
you know you're being looked after and
just press the button checking in on
people like Anne by phone are the staff
of the NHS at home program a partnership
between Community Healthcare and local
hospitals more than 160 000 people have
already occupied virtual beds on the
UK's National Health Service are you
feeling short of breath at all this room
does of course look nothing like a busy
Hospital Ward but the four clinicians
here are today monitoring 70 patients
remotely in their homes all of whom
would otherwise be taking up hospital
beds currently being used by more
seriously ill patients if the data from
their testing kit shows a decline a
doctor or nurse is sent out to them for
safety sake interventions can happen
quicker than on regular Wards we're
looking closely for the patients having
any deterioration really it's a case of
being quite reactive with patients that
are unwell whereas when you're in a ward
you can
potentially
um potentially wait a bit more
um you can't I'll let you get that
to get it let's hope the service can
also prevent infections spreading in
hospital and it's now being expanded to
give terminally ill children care at
home with their families hello
biology
there we've already looked at robots in
the inverted commas but we have to think
about the personal touch and I think
that's what this um you know what this
really provides research has suggested
that up to 80 percent of Britain's would
favor this kind of treatment with
waiting lists at a record high and
doctors on strike overpay monitoring
vital signs from the sofa may become
more of a necessity than a choice Paul
Reese Al Jazeera Bristol England
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al Jazeera